انها الرئيس التونسيه وقيس سعيد مهام
وزيره التجاره وتنميه الصادرات من دون ذكر
الاسباب ياتي هذا غداه اعلان معهد الاحصاء
الحكوميه ارتفاع نسبه التضخم لاعلى مستوى
منذ اربعه عقود وارتفاع اسعار السلع
والخدمه بجانبه انتقد الاتحاد التونسي
للشغل سياسات سعيد وخياراته الاقتصادي بان
الاتحاد لا يمكنه السكوت على هذا الوضع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي خيارات الرئيس
التونسيه للتعامل مع ازمه نقص المواد
الاساسيه وارتفاع اسعارها وما النتائج
التي يمكن ان تترتب على اقاله وزيره
التجاره باعتبارها المسؤوله عن هذا الملف
اي انعكاسات للازمه الاقتصاديه الحاده
التي يواجهها التونسيون على المسار
السياسي المتازم اصلا وكيف سيتعامل للرئيس
مع تهديد الكيانات النقابيه بالتسعيده ما
هي اوراق القوى السياسيه المعارضه في
مواجهه الرئيس على ضوء دعوتها للتظاهر ضده
الاسبوع المقبل وما رؤيتها لاخراج البلاد
من اسماءتها الرهينه
[موسيقى]
في اول قالت لوزير في حكومه نجلاء بدن
التي بدات ولايتها في اكتوبر عام 2021
انها الرئيس التونسي مهام وزيره التجاره
وتنميه الصادرات في وقت تواجهه في السلطه
انتقادات واسعه بسبب ازمه حاده تجلد في
فقدان العديد من المواد الاساسيه وارتفاع
اسعارها واكد عمقها معهد الاحصاء التونسي
الحكومي الذي قال قبل يومين ان نسبه تضخم
في تونس ارتفعت خلال الشهر الماضي الى
اعلى مستوى لها منذ اربعه عقود شهاده تضاف
الى توقعات محافظ البنك المركزي التونسيه
يوم الاربعاء بارتفاع نسبه تضخم خلال
السنه الحاليه والارتفاع الكبير في اسعار
بعض السلع خلال السنوات المقبله
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من تونس جوهره
بن مبارك القيادي في جبهه الخلاص الوطني
ومن تونس ايضا جمال مارس القيادي في
التيار الشعبي ابدا معك سيد جمال اذن
الارقام والمؤشرات الاقتصاديه سيئه جدا
وفقا للمؤسسات التابعه للحكومه التونسيه
ما الذي اوصل البلاد الى هذا المستوى
سيد جمال
مساء الخير تحيه لكم ولكافه مشاهدي قناه
هناك قطاع في الصوت لو السيد التقنيين
يعالجون المساله لاني لا اسمع لم اسمع
السؤال
في محاوله للتاكد ان كان يصل اليك سالت عن
الاسباب التي ادت الى وصول الازمه
الاقتصاديه في تونس الى هذا الدرس
الى ان نعالج هذا الخلل انتقل الى السيد
جوهر من مبارك سيد جوهر بتقديرك ما هي
الاسباب التي ادت للوصول تونس لهذا
المستوى على الجانب الاقتصادي وهل قالت
وزيره التجاره ستغير الوضع والنحشه
الحكوميه
نعم تحيه لك ولكل المشاهدين قناه الجزيره
ايه الحقيقه ان تونس تعيش وضع اقتصادي صعب
ومتدرج في صعوبته منذ سنوات طويله وهذا
امر معلوم وربما ادى الى ااا احتقان الوضع
السياسي وتعثر الانتقال الديمقراطي بشكل
عام على امتداد العشريه الماضيه ولكن
الازمه همم
استفحلت بشكل غير مسبوق وصارت همم لا
تحتمل والشعب التونسي الان يدفع فاتوره
غاليه جدا خاصه بعد انقلاب 25 جويليه كل
المؤشرات الماليه والاقتصاديه والمؤشرات
النمو والتنميه تراجعت بشكل كبير وشكل غير
مسبوق في السنه والنصف المنقذيه طبعا هذا
سببه اولا وجود البلاد في همم
اتون ازمه سياسيه همم حاده نتيجه انقلاب
قيس سعيد على الشرعيه
وتعطيل عمل المؤسسات الدوله
والاستئثار بالقرار والسلطه همم المسار
طبعا قيس سعيد لم يكن مهتما وليس مهتما
الى الان بالشان الاقتصادي والملف
الاقتصادي والملف المالي همم ولكنه مهتم
اكثر
بتوطيل اصول سلطته ووضع النصوص والايط
والقطر المؤسساتيه لتثبيت سلطه الفرد
بان الرئيس غير مهتم بشان الاقتصادي اذا
كيف تفسرون اقاله وزيره التجاره وهي
المسؤوله عن ملف الاقتصادي
نعم ااااه
قيس سعيد حاول ان يتدخل وكل ما وضع يده في
الملف الاقتصادي الا واربكا اما انه يربك
ماكينه الانتاج وراينا هذا في الكثير من
الحالات عندما ينتقل ويمش ببعض القطاعات
او يربط منظومه التوزيع في البلاد وهذا
احدث شلل كبيرا وزاد في التين بله ثم
اقاله وزيره همم
يعني التجاره هو امر غريب لان السرديه
التي رواها قيس سعيد منذ اشهر منذ ان بدات
ازمه التموين وازمه غلاء الاسعار في
البلاد كان يوجه اصابع الاتهام اولا
للمحتكرين والمضاربين وثانيا لمعارضين
السياسيين همم ويقول بان كل هذه الازمات
هي الازمات مفتعله من طرف المنويين
والخونه واعداء وخصومه السياسيين همم الان
باقاله وزيره الخارج همم التجاره هو يقر
بان الازمه هي ازمه اداء حكومي وازمه اداء
همم منظومته وليست ازمه في وجود المحتكرين
والمعارضين همم السياسيين لو ان القمر
سيد جمال يعني هل قالت وزيره التجاره ستحل
الازمه الاقتصاديه التي تعيشها تونس السيد
جوهر ربطه بين استفحال الازمه والنهج
المعتمد من قبل الرئيس السعيد وقال بان
الاسباب التي كان يسوقها الرئيس سعيد
انتهت مع اقاله وزيره التجاره
تحيه من جديد طبعا جاءت اقاله وزيره
التجاره يوم امس في اطار بساعي رئيس
الجمهوريه الى معالجه المس الى الاقتصاديه
ومن وراءها المثل الاجتماعيه اعوذ واتفاعل
مع ضيفكم في خصوص الاسباب التي رماها على
مسار 25 جويل على قيد سعيد وفقد تريد ان
نذكر ان العشريه الثالثه تضمت مرحله
استنزاف للماليه العموميه ومرحله مديونيه
غير مسبوقه في تاريخ تونس جعلت اليوم
ميزانيه 2023 مطالب خلاص بنسبه خلاص
المديونيه تصير في حدود 24% من ميزانيه
تونس معده لخلاص ما تركته همم
حكام العشريه السوداء وبالتالي ما يعاديه
25 جوي لهم ويعني حكم المرحله الحاليه
للسياسه المديونيه المفرطه والمشرطه
هل الحكومه السابقه او العهد السابق هو من
يفاوت صندوق النقد الدولي يعني عثرت
المفاوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي من يتحمل
مسؤوليه ذلك هل ايه قالت وزيره التجاره
ستحل المشكله في ما كان يقول الرئيس
السعيد ان الازمه الاقتصاديه تعود اسباب
الى المعارضين واداء المعارضين ووضع العصي
امام الدواليب
في خصوص مسائل التوفير الماليه العموميه
وتوفير الموارد اللازمه الماليه العموميه
هذا مطالب بهاء الحكومه الحاليه مهما كانت
معناها همم الاسباب الاخرى وبالتالي عليهم
ان يتفاعلوا ان يجدوا الحلول ان يحدث
القرارات الثوريه وقلنا في بيان 20 من هذا
الشهر
نتائج الانتخابات حملنا رئيس الجمهوريه
عدم تعيده للكفاءات اللازمه تركيه لعديد
المناصب شاغره داخل الجمهوريه محمد كذلك
همم عدم اتخاذ قرارات ثوريه وعدم معالجه
مسائل مهمه اقتصاديه واجتماعيه بالشكل
المطلوب هذا مساله موضوعيه لا نختلف فيها
مع احد وبالتالي نحن مع دعوه الى الان
عندما تحرك رئيس الجمهوريه بهذا الشكل
فبالتالي طبعا وزيره التجاره مسؤول على
القطاع عليها ان تعالج الاحتكار بشكل
مطلوب ان تتحرك باعتبارها مسؤوله على هذا
المجال وان كان هناك احتكار وان هناك
بالعجله مثل ما يقال هناك كذلك الخارج
الذي رفع فيتو بشكل كبير على هذه السلطه
25 جويليه وعدم مد اي مساعده مهما كانت
سواء من الدول العربيه من الخليجيه من
الاوروبيه من الامريكان وغير ذلك رغم سعي
رئيس الجمهوريه رغم الدبلوماسيه الخارجيه
في عام قيس سعيد قد اشتغلت بشكل جيد جدا
اقول من خلال تنظيم قبه اكاد من خلال
تقييم من القبه والفريق الفونيه من خلال
المشاركه في القمه الافريقيه الامريكيه من
خلال مشاركه في القمه الصينيه الامريكيه
هناك اذكرك سيدتي الكريمه ان دول الخليجيه
ساعدت تركيا رغبه
عشره مليون دولار في البنك المركزي وخمسه
مليون دولار والم يسلم ولهم واحد
تونس وبماذا تفسر لنا هذا سيدتي الكريمه
انا اسال عليك ان تجيب بطريقه التي
تفسر لماذا تفسرون
مساعده خارجيه لتونس ولماذا لا على
اقاله وزيره التجاره ونعتبرها خطوه
ايجابيه لابد من البناء عليها بان الرئيس
اليوم انما يلتفت الى الوضع الاقتصادي
المتردي في البلاد
التي تعيش فيها تونس العزله الدوليه التي
سجل بها قيس سعيد البلاد بعد ما كانت تونس
يعني تجربه رائده دوليا ومفره على المستوى
الدولي والمضرب امثال في نجاح التجربه
الديمقراطيه الوحيده في همم منظومه الربيع
العربي همم طبعا هذا
امر واضح وهي فاتوره يدفعها التونسيون
والتونسيات وتدفعوا البلاد نتيجه السياسه
النعناها التي ذهب فيها قيس سعيد وضرب
الانتقال الديمقراطي واستفرد بالسلطه همم
قيس سعيد كان يعني يوجه الاتهامات والتهكم
على مؤسسات التصنيف ثم التونسيون بعد ذلك
يدفعون الثمن كان يتهكم على صندوق النقد
الدولي والبنك الدولي ثم التونسيون بعد
ذلك يدفعون الثمن سعيد لا يستمعوا الى
الدول والى الاصدقاء والى الاصدقاء تونس
ولم يعطي ولو تنازلا واحدا في اتجاه عوده
الديمقراطي
وهذا ادى الى عزله تونس واكبر دليل على
هذا ان صندوق النقد الدولي لجنه المخاطر
في صندوق الدوله التي اجلت همم وعلقت
العمل بالملف التونسي بر ذلك باسباب
سياسيه بالمخاطر السياسيه بنسبه المخاطر
المرتفعه على مستواه ولكن هل يتحمل الرئيس
مسؤوليه الازمه الاقتصاديه الم ياتي
الرئيس وهنالك تركه ثقيله اقتصاديه في
تونس الم يكن هنالك ازمه اوكرانيا والحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا وتداعيات ذلك على
الاقتصاد العالمي ليس فقط في تونس
طبعا هناك اسباب يعني همم دافعه وهناك وضع
موضوع على سواء على مستوى الوضع الاقتصادي
التونسي او على المستوى الدولي ولكن اداء
قيس سعيد همم زاد الطينه بالله لم يستطيع
لم تستطع هذه المنظومه
التحشد اي نوع من انواع الاحتياط
الاقتصادي والمالي تحسبا لمثل هذه الاوضاع
هذه هذه المنظومه لم تستطع ان تحل ولو
ملفا واحدا ولو همم يعني تفصيلا واحدا
وانا اتحدى كل من يدعم قيس سعيد وكل حتى
يراقب الوضع في تونس ما هو الملف الوحيد
حتى وان كان تافهه حتى وان كان صغيرا الذي
استطاع قيس سعيد ان يحله لا تحدث عن الملف
الاقتصادي يتحدث على ملفات هامشيه همم
استطاع قيس سعيد ان يحل له على امتداد يا
عم ونصف من السلطه المطلقه بكل الامتيازات
وكل صلاحيات هو الذي قال يوم 25 جويريه
مؤسسات بالدبابات ولدي الحلول لكل مشاكل
اين هي الحلول ربطت الاقتصاد
باسياسه هذا ايضا ما فعله عدد من القاده
ضمن سلسله انتقادات واجهتها قياده وازنه
في الاتحاد لعام التونسي للشغل للسياسات
الرئيس سعيد خلال الايام الماضيه حمل
الامين العام المساعد الاتحاد لعام
التونسيه للشغل احفظ الرئيس مسؤوليه مالت
اليه البلاد وانتقد خيارته لمعالجه الازمه
الاقتصاديه الراهنه التي اعتبرها التجليا
لازمه سياسيه خلقها الرئيس
طلبيه سياسيه لكن اسبابها هو الانقلاب على
مسار 25 جويلي رئيس الجمهوريه وفعل الفصل
الثاني هو الضبابيه نتيجه المسار
الانفرادي اللي جسمه رئيس الجمهوريه بعد
شهرين بازار المرسوم عدد 117 واللي جمع
فيه السلطات الثلاث بين يديه
على ان صياغه الدستور لتكون تشاركيا حتى
الحوار العالي كان سوريا قلب حتى على اقرب
الناس له من جهه بيضه القانون الدستوري
الضبابيه الحال لما انفرد بنفسه بصياغه
قانون الانتخاب على قياسه ارغفه الاجسام
الوسيطه الاحزاب والغف فيه كل المكونات
السياسيه في البلاد
سيد جمال يعني الاتحاد العام للشغل ربط
بين الاداء السياسي والازمه الاقتصاديه
التي تعيشها البلاد في تونس ومعلوم موقف
الاتحاد العام للشغل وتاييده لما جرى في
الخامس والعشرين بذلك الا يكون الرئيس قد
فقد حليفا
اساسيا له حتى الاتحاد العام للشغل اليوم
ينتقد اداءه السياسي
سيد جمال
نعم اعتذر على الاستماع في خصوص موضوع
اتحاد العام التونسي للشغل طبعا يجب ان
نفهم تركيبه الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
ونذكره ان معنى هذا الاتحاد هو اتحادات ان
يتركب من منخاري كثير على مستوى قاعده ثم
نقابات اساسيه ثم اتحاد جهويه ثم جامعات
اداريه في مكتب تنفيذي واذكر استشهاد 2011
عند ايامات الثوره ان الامين العام باقي
يتفاوض مع عبد العزيز الى اخر لحظه وان
القواعد خرجت الى الشارع ودعم
البصار الثوري وبالتالي هذا ملك الازمات
هذه تركيبه الاتحاد التي تعتبره يعني
يختلف من حيث موقف القياده الى مختلف نعم
اريد ان افسر بصوره مبدئيه
على مستويات مختلفه داخل الاتحاد العامه
للشغل وليس فقط من السيد حفيظ
والاضطرابات التي تقوم بها النقابات انما
خير دليل على الانتقاد والاعتراض وضع في
البلاد
سيد جمال
هناك قطاع في الصوت للاسف سيدتي الكريمه
ارجو ان تتركني انهي فكرتي اردت ان اشرح
وان افهم للمشاهد ما معنى اتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل الاتحاد
وكثره المقاطعه طفله ما تركتي ضيفك يتحدث
بكل دحيه ارجو ترك التحدث بكل اريحيه وهذا
اسلوب معتمد داخل قناه الجزيره مع الصوت
الاخر والمعارض طيب
لاخر مره انا قطعت السيد جوهر سابقا
سيد جمال
طيب عود مره جديده الى السيد جوهر سيد
جوهر يؤخذ عليكم ايضا بانكم انتم يعني
تنتقدون ولكن لا تطعه لا تضعون اي خطه
اقتصاديه لا تقدمون اي بدائل وان الصف
المعارض اساسا غير موحد في مواجهه الرئيس
سعيد
فقط اردت ان اقول ضيفك لانني انا من امثل
صوت المعارضه وليس هو يمثل صوت المولات في
الحكم
يعني بالنسبه للمعارضه
والبرنامج الاقتصادي نحن في جبهه الخلاص
نخبه نشتغل الان على هذا الامر ونشتغل على
اعداد تصور للخروج من الازمه الاقتصاديه
ولكن ال- ال- المعضله ليست هذه الاقتصاد
هو جزء من السياسه عندما تكون هناك حياه
سياسيه مغلقه تماما همم لا يمكن لقوى
المعارضه والقوه السياسيه التي صارت كل
تقريبا المشهد الوطني خارج دائره القرار
وخارج دائره الصراع السياسي والتنافس
السياسي وامكانيه تمرير همم يعني الافكار
نحن في دوله مغلقه الان وفي منظومه سياسيه
مغلقات وفي حياه سياسيه مغلقه كل اقتراحات
المعارضات تبقى اقتراحات نظريه لا يمكن
همم تقديمها او حتى نعمل في ان تكون لها
اي فاعليه على الارض على الواقعه كان ممكن
في زمن كان فيه برلمان تعدديا
الافكار في جوهر ذكرتم في البدايه بانكم
تعملون على خطه الم يتاخر الوقت لعرض هذه
الخطه اجابه سريعه حتى عود السيد جمال
الاجابه سهله نعرضها على من نعرضها في
مشهد سياسي مغلق وفي حياه سياسيه مغلقه
وفي سلطه لا تستمع الى احد
ودوله لا تستمع الى احد ورئيس لا يتحاور
مع احد وحكومه لا يراقبها احد انا قلت لك
ان كان هناك برلمان مثلا وليس برلمان
مغلقا بالدبابه كان من الممكن ان يكون هذا
فضاء للنقاش
وكاله
ناسا في السنوات في السنوات الماضيه
قوانين الماليه كانت تناقش بجديه داخل
البرلمان الان لا يوجد اي نقاش حول قانون
الماليه وحاول السياسات الاقتصاديه
للمعارضه ليس لها منبر حتى تستطيع ان تقدم
وجهه نظرهاها تفضل سيد جمال ما تعليقكم
على ما ذكره السيد جوهر
الحمد لله انا ما باسمعش فيك ما كنتش اسمع
فيك طبعا هو كان هناك قطاع في الصوت لم
اسمع كامل ال ال الموقف وكامل الحديث ولكن
اريد ان اؤكد مره اخرى على ان ما يذهب
اليه اتحاد الشغل هو محاوله الى العوده
الى المشهد السياسي يحاول بعد ان غيب
الغابه اكثر من سنه او سنه ونص اليوم
الاتحاد الشغل لم يشارك في الدستور ولم
يشارك في الانتخابات اليوم المكتب
التنفيذي لاتحاد الشغل له قراءته الخاصه
له موقفه الخاص اتحاد الشغل له دور وطني
تاريخي منذ الاستعمار ولكن مع الاستقلال
مع هذا لا يكره احد وتدخله في مثل
السياسيه وان كان مؤقتا عليه في بعض
المواقف لكنه مقبول ولكن الاتحاد الحالي
اول هيئه الاداريه او البث بالتنفيذ
الحالي له حساباته هناك نقابات سيده
الكريمه مثل بقى الفكره التي لم تترك
يديها انه هناك جامعه قريبه من مكتب
التنفيذ الحالي وهنا اللقب مثل التعليم
وغيره
اعتقد لا تنسى جنب هذا ال- ال- المكتب
التنفيذ الحالي مكتب تنفيذ الحالي استعمل
لقابه النقل
ونقل نعرف الاضراب والنقل واهميته على
مستوى الاقتصاد وعلى مستوى الحركيه
الاجتماعيه وادي ذلك يستعمل هذه النقابات
لشل ربما والضغط على مسار 25 جويلي اعوان
السلطه الحاليه رقم مثل الاضراب الفجعي
والوحشي يوم الاثنين الفارق وبالتالي
الاتحاد ليس صدق الله العظيم وبالتالي
التي حاد لا يمثل اراده جماعه الشغالين
الهيئه الحاليه وبالتالي هو موقف سياسي
الضغط
الدرجه الاولى
من تونس الوطني
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]